si el g20 aportará los fondos necesarios
para financiar la vacuna contra el
coronavirus a los países más pobres los
líderes prometieron no escatimar
esfuerzos para asegurar un acceso
asequible y equitativo para todos sin
embargo la cancillera alemana dijo estar
preocupada porque aún no se ha negociado
nada concreto para asegurar la vacuna a
las naciones de menos recursos el
mandatario mexicano planteó quitar
montos y pagos de deuda a los países más
pobres un endeudamiento que ha crecido
por la pandemia en un promedio del 20
por ciento en algunos países hacer
realidad el compromiso de quitar montos
de deuda y del pago de servicio de la
deuda a naciones pobres del mundo
garantizar que los países ingresos
medios puedan tener acceso a créditos
con tasas de interés equivalentes a las
que están vigentes en países
desarrollados el presidente chino
coincidió con lópez obrador y pidió
hacer esfuerzos para priorizar el
desarrollo y crear un entorno económico
favorable para todo
el medio ambiente fue otro de los temas
en la agenda del g20 el saliente
presidente de eeuu defendió su decisión
de retirar a su país del acuerdo
climático de parís que plantea reducir
las emisiones de gases de efecto
invernadero y retire a eeuu del injusto
y unilateral acuerdo climático de parís
un hecho injusto para eeuu el acuerdo de
parís fue diseñado para matar la
economía estadounidense
carme soluciones multilaterales eficaces
a las crisis
el presidente francés concluyó así
agregando que el mundo necesita una
respuesta coordinada y unida para
combatir los problemas en el mundo
arabia saudita que lideró la cumbre
entregó la presidencia del g20 a italia
este domingo al concluirse la cita
virtual